let's imagine that um i'm the president
or you're talking to the president i
know you you've been uh advising the
biden campaign
um is that correct i advised biden on
deep fakes
uh two years ago when they three years
ago
pretty yeah pretty recent vintage um
what are the safeguards and
countermeasures that we could install
because a lot of people listening to
this right now nina are like oh my gosh
like i give up like i think i'm watching
andrew yang talk to nina sheik but maybe
i'm not
like you know this whole thing could
just be like a giant fabrication which
it could be theoretically
how do we know so so you do make some
suggestions but would love to talk to
you about what possible solutions
look like what could we do if let's say
hypothetically we have control of the
government of the united states of
america
2021 we look up and say all right we
have to
address this problem broadly the
solutions kind of fall into two
categories
the first is the technical solutions so
building the ai software to detect video
manipulations because as
synthetic media so yeah so let's start
with that nina
like let's say you're russia and you
make a hundred synthetic
media videos and audio recordings
do we have the technology right now that
could go through and be like fake fake
fake fake fake fake and then there's one
real one in there and be like real
so right
is the answer because there are several
kind of deep fake detection tools but
given that they can be generated using
different kind of
machine learning systems there's no one
detection tool that can detect them all
and the other crazy thing about trying
to build
the detection tools is that every time
you think you build a really cool piece
of software ai software to
detect all the fakes um you're giving
the person who's making the fakes a
a foot up so it's always going to be a
cat and mouse game so
there are some tools out there there's
no one universal tool is the short
answer
could you have a tool that gives you
like a spectrum of probability
where you could say this thing is
probably real
this thing might be fake uh within like
a certain measure of confidence i get
that you can't
categorically say real fake but you
could be like we think this one's
probably real
or we think this one's probably fake
yeah and and that is how those detection
tools work right now the ones that are
already out there they're like oh this
is 90
probably synthetic um but
uh i would say that because we're just
at the start of this
synthetic media revolution like we
haven't actually
come to the stage yet where it's
ubiquitous but in four years time
when it is time for the next election
some experts who i speak to think that
as much as 90 percent of video content
online could be synthetic
so oh gosh
there is an urgency which
isn't so it hasn't hit us yet but in
four years time we're looking at
something
completely different i actually think
this election
is more likely to be disrupted by
something called the liar's dividend
if everything can be faked then
everything can also be denied
and that is something called the liar's
dividend and
you already see that happening now and
this is something that's only going to
get
more potent as time goes on there's
actually one candidate a republican
candidate standing for congress
who took the george floyd video that
powerful video which
unleashed a movement not only across the
us
but across the world and she's written a
24-page document saying
that it's a deep fake so you're going to
see a lot more of that
okay so there isn't an easy technical
fix
you can have some ai tools that catch
some degree
of uh synthetic media or some
proportion of it but not enough where
you can say problem solved so what else
what else lies in the technique okay so
so that the one the first part of
technical solutions is detection
the second part is provenance right so
you
actually try to prove what media
is authentic and this is going to become
increasingly important for like
activists journalists people who are
trying to record
something and hold um someone either to
account
as a kind of human rights abuse or to
show that what they have done
is authentic and you basically try and
embed that into almost the hardware
of your phone or your camera it's almost
like a watermark which is indelible
you can't tamper it so that always is
shown to be authentic
so those are the kind of two technical
solutions detection
and provenance but ultimately
this isn't a pro this isn't a technology
problem in the sense that the technology
here
until i mean we have fully sentient ai
which we don't
the technology is just an amplifier of
human intention
so the real solution comes with
policy legal uh
digital and digital literacy and
education
this is something that just the
technology isn't going to make go away
it's something that
society needs to grasp as a national
security and i would say
you know one of the most important
issues for the future of liberal
democracy so
we need people like you who understand
how technology is reshaping politics and
society and then can
communicate that to the public in a way
that they understand what's at stake
here
then only can i hope that there is kind
of the political and public will
galvanized in order to make this uh
the priority which i believe it needs to
be because
i think there's a short window in which
something can still be done
and otherwise the kind of vested powers
that benefit from the information
ecosystem being
the way that it is it becomes
increasingly difficult
to do anything about it so
right now in the united states we have
deep skepticism
of the media i think that trust in media
that um
i saw most recently was 41 the major
media organizations
and it runs the gamut uh along party
lines
so if you are a democrat in the united
states of america you trust the national
media at a higher level let's call it 58
or 60 percent and then independents are
around 40
and then republicans are at something
like 20
so so that's the it's been migrating
downward over
time so that's where we are right now
so then if you go and say look we have
to get our arms around this
uh and establish what the heck is real
and what's not real like what's true and
false you have a significant proportion
of the american people already that are
like whatever you're doing
like i don't trust it is nonsense like
you know you're trying to control me
control us
and there's a very very deep heritage in
the u.s
which i agree with freedom of the press
freedom of information
like censorship is terrible and it seems
like if you're trying to establish
what's
real or true then what you're really
trying to do is censor the heck out of
a bunch of people so that's like the the
current landscape
um and then you go to them and say no
look this is a massive problem
like you don't even know if i'm real
right now because i'm talking to
a video screen
so we would need to line up in my view
major media organizations major
technology companies
uh nonprofits and the government
and get everyone together and say all
right like let us try and establish some
standards some rules of the road
to say that uh you have to use these
devices and if you don't use these
devices
then it will be marked as don't know if
this is real
uh you know and that can include our
cell phones so at least you know if i
take a cell phone video it's attributed
to me and like
you know so it's not like you
necessarily need to have a giant camera
from
um from cnn or wherever but like there
needs to be some
uh prominence to your point there needs
to be some kind of chain of ownership
of this and then someone like puts their
name on and says yeah
i was there and that happened um so
that's the challenge is trying to
bring that coalition together and then
try and get this trust
in whatever standards you establish
to rise over time if you look at
other places where society-wide
mobilization to disinformation has been
really effective
take for example the small baltic state
of estonia
some three million people they've often
been in the eye of kind of russian
disinformation campaigns
and they've really turned it around by
basically adopting
what you just pointed out which is a
whole society-wide mobilization where
you have
kind of industry working with policy
makers working with citizens working
with ngos
but taking that networked approach is
really difficult
um and i would say that if the current
presidency continues in the united
states then that challenge becomes
even more difficult because what's quite
clear
is that the president has a vested
interest in making sure that the
information ecosystem
is corroded he is one of the biggest
purveyors of disinformation
and if this continues for another four
years
i find it difficult to see the way
back for the united states no that's the
argument that so many people are making
is that we can't handle four more years
of trump i happen to agree with that
i i think that four more years of
disintegration
uh will lead us to a point where it's
very difficult to come back
um though many people think of it for
different reasons than what you're
describing
you know but that there have been folks
who've said
that u.s democracy itself is on the line
yeah and i i don't think that's an
exaggeration at all because
if i mean a democracy can only work
liberal democracy
can only work if you have some kind of
objective reality and some commitment to
truth and the pursuit of truth
if the pursuit of truth no longer
matters then the only thing that matters
is
power and who has the power to control
narratives
so that then ends up becoming very
authoritarian
like you know what what this is nina
like this is a problem that prevents us
from solving other problems
uh and so that and so that that's where
my attention is focused right
now is um is we have to fix the
machinery
of democracy uh and at this point
it's not enough to try and get the right
people embedded into the machine you
have to try and fix the machine itself
because right now this machine uh that
this machine is breaking down in a way
that even if i stuck like a good person
uh in congress it's not going to save us
absolutely focus on the architecture the
machine i think we're
absolutely on the same page here andrew
i'm going to become the mechanic
nina and i know you are too thank you so
much for edifying us
nina's book is deep fakes the coming
infocalipse
uh it's compelling it's scary and
hopefully we will do something about it
together
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]